مدينه نيويورك بدات تغرق بالفعل وقريبا قد
يكون تمثال الحريه الشهير مجرد ذكرى كلمات
صادمه بالتاكيد لكنها الحقيقه بحسب دراسه
نشرت على مجله
فما السبب في هذا الامر ارتفاعه مستوى
البحر حول المدينه باكثر من ضعف المعدل
العالمي ويتوقع حدوث ذلك بحلول عام
2050 وبما بين ثماني بساط وثلاثين بوصه
السبب الثاني هو وزن مبانيها الكلي لتقريب
الصوره اكثر الباحثون حسب كتله اكثر من
مليون مبنى في الاحياء الخمسه لمدينه
نيويورك والاستنتاج كان ان هذه المباني
تزن ما يعادل
762 مليار كيلوغرام ولمعرفه مدى الكارثه
مشاهدينا هذا الوزن يعادل تقريبا مليونير
طائره من طراز 7 فور
ومحمله بالكامل لا يشمل هذا الرقم بالطبع
البنيه التحتيه لوسائل النقل التي تربط
المدينه ولا نحو ثمانيه ملايين ونصف
المليون شخص يسكنها المعدل المتوسط لغرق
المنطقه ومبانيها هو من مليمتر واحد الى
مليمترين سنويا لكن مناطق من حاتم بروكلين
وكوينز ستغرق بمعدل اسرع من المتوسط اربعه
مليمترات الثانويه هي الاكثر حيويه
واكتضاضا بالطبع لكن نيويورك ليست وحدها
في هذا الخطر امستردام البصره البندقيه
وبانكوك مدن اخرى تواجه هذا الخطر لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات